[Musica]
[Applauso]
cagna
io non mi ha chiamato così
la prima volta che mi hanno chiamato
avevo 14 anni
era l'estate del 2008
e i miei genitori dopo aver scoperto che
avevo iniziato a sperimentare ed
esplorare con la mia sessualità decisero
di pulirmi allontanandomi dal mio
fidanzato dell'epoca e mandandomi a
passare le vacanze al mare
li conobbi tania una ragazza più piccola
di me con la quale inizia subito ad
uscire
sarà stato l'odore del mare gli ormoni a
palla all chi cazzo vuoi ma chi te
conosce fame fa la vita mia tipico del
capricorno ma dopo qualche giorno di
profondo dolore tristezza per aver
abbandonato il mio fidanzato
io taglie iniziamo ad uscire con un
gruppo di ragazzi del posto
c'era paolo con i muscoli costretti da
magliette sempre più attillate andrea il
giullare del gruppo e fra l'eterno amico
le giornate passarono leggere tra gelati
messaggini d'amore cominciate sugli
scogli
inutile dirvi che quella che mi sembra
essere una punizione terribile finì per
essere una gran botta di culo
c'era un problema però
quei ragazzi con cui tanto ci
divertivamo non erano liberi non
disponevano del loro corpo della facoltà
di scegliere erano di proprietà ero di
qualcun'altra e loro proprietarie non
tardarono nella avvisarci ci dissero che
quelli erano i loro ragazzi e ci
consigliarono per così dire di smetterla
di frequentarli
io tania
impavide teenager noi ed e moretta
il risultato fu trovare i nostri nomi
scritti con land il è bill e sul muro di
fronte a casa a costate la parola
giulia e tania zoccole
a 14 anni senza saperlo mi ero scontrata
con uno stigma che mi avrebbe
accompagnata per tutta la vita
uno stigma di genere che attraversa la
biografia di tutte le donne
lo stigma della
lo stigma della è un preciso
dispositivo di controllo che non
disciplina soltanto la sessualità
femminile ma la condotta femminile del
suo complesso
è uno strumento che è pronto a
sanzionarci a colpirci attraversiamo il
confine
quando mettiamo in discussione la
gerarchia su cui si struttura il sistema
patriarcale
quando ci appropriamo di ruoli qualità
atteggiamenti che in quanto donne non
dovremmo avere
quella scritta sul muro voleva
ricordarmi proprio questo che stavo
andando oltre delle regole imposte che
quello non era il mio posto che quello
non era il mio ruolo
lo stigma della è dunque una
minaccia costante che gravita nella vita
di tutte le donne non essere aggressiva
non importi non urlare non mostrarti non
godere altrimenti ti danno della
altrimenti sei una devi
scegliere buona brava compiacente oppure
ribelle aggressiva esuberante santa o
garda lerner nel suo libro the creation
of patriarchi ci dice che nell'antica
mesopotamia con il codice hammurabi sii
tu toschi istituzionalizzò una prima
gerarchia tra donne dal lato le donne
rispettabili le mogli le figlie nubili
le concubine e dall'altro le donne
pubbliche le schiave e le prostitute
e si decise che per evitare di
confonderle le prime dovessero indossare
un velo
ecco chi lo stigma è un marchio è un
segno un elemento di distinzione di
differenziazione di separazione tra
donne che ancora oggi ci divide facendo
così il gioco del patriarcato
la
rappresenta ciò che non dovremmo essere
colei che non dovremmo mai diventare
la sfida l'assetto culturale
patriarcale che ci vorrebbe come angeli
del focolare oggetti ma i soggetti prede
mai predatrici la irrompe
fisicamente e simbolicamente in uno
spazio pubblico che storicamente non le
appartiene
e non a caso viene spesso definita con
termini che ne evidenziano l'esteriorità
peripatetica lucciola stradaiola
passeggiatrice è il asfaltica scrive
vergini the pound in king kong earl
la sfugge al controllo
patriarcale e per questo fa paura
incarna la moralità la trasgressione fa
qualcosa che una donna non dovrebbe mai
fare
usa in modo autonomo il proprio corpo ne
trae profitto se lo fa di mestiere
sono un'educatrice sessuale
crea contenuti per adulti online
e faccio parte di swipe un'associazione
di sex worker e alleate che farà il suo
esordio a breve che abbiamo creato per
offrire supporto e comunità alle persone
che fanno sex worker
in italia e in gran parte del mondo le
persone che fanno lavoro sessuale e
dunque vendono servizi e contenuti per
adulti
non sono riconosciute in quanto
lavoratrici
il lavoro sessuale non viene
riconosciuto in quanto lavoro chi fa
lavoro sessuale vive sulla propria pelle
gli effetti di politiche proibizioniste
classiste sessiste e razziste
spesso mascherate da intenti
caritatevoli
chi fa lavoro sessuale subisce un
infantilizzazione e una vittimizzazione
costante non sai quello che fai se una
schiava del sesso se la vittima non ti
preoccupare ci siamo noi ti di salvia
moquette indichiamo la retta via
se fino alla fine dell'ottocento
la prostituta era considerata per natura
patologica
e quindi recuperabile con la comparsa
del sociale come ambito lavorativo
si costruisce il soggetto prostituta e
con esso l'idea che la prostituzione non
sia dipesa da cause biologiche bensì
sociali e che dunque possa essere
evitata come
attraverso opere di rieducazione
affidate alle donne bianchi borghesi
in quel periodo storico che coincide con
il consolidamento dei valori borghesi e
l'entrata in scena delle donne le donne
bianche borghesi ovviamente
l'immagine della prostituta ville e
pericolosa potente viene sostituita dall
immagine della prostituta povera
incapace da salvare
strategicamente dalla paura si passa
alla pietà
restituendo così il potere a chi crede
di poterci salvare marchiando c tutte in
via definitiva come vittime
e questa vittimizzazione tipica del
modello abolizionista è estremamente
pericolosa e pericolosa perché spoglie
le donne e del loro potere personale
nella loro capacità di autodeterminarsi
si fa lavoro sessuale
vive tutti i giorni svariate forme di
violenza
dall'insulto la negazione dei diritti
fondamentali da una violenza fisica
l'emarginazione sociale
ma la violenza che vivono le persone che
fanno sex worker non è costitutiva del
sex worker cioè lo sfruttamento la
violenza non c'è perché c'è il sex
worker
si tratta di una violenza strutturale
nel gennaio del 2004
sandra cabrera fu uccisa da un ufficiale
di polizia in argentina
nel febbraio del 2020 jessica sarmiento
fu investita da un'auto con a bordo tre
uomini a parigi
nell'aprile dello stesso anno stefania
maria rosa busi fu uccisa nel suo
appartamento a milano
cabrera sarmiento ed usi avevano
qualcosa in comune
erano delle donne una di loro una donna
trans ed erano delle sex worker erano
delle sex worker che sono state uccise
da uomini
questa si chiama violenza di genere
eppure anche all'interno di femminismi
spesso si parla della violenza che viene
i mercati del sesso come se fosse
qualcosa di diverso che non ci riguarda
che riguarda le altre le le
immigrate ma questa violenza ci riguarda
tutti e tutti perché è figlia della
stessa matrice patriarcale da cui
nascono tutte le forme di violenza che
riguardano le donne
la violenza che vivono le sex worker è
una violenza di genere e continuare a
distinguere tratta sfruttamento dalla
violenza di genere non fa altro che
inasprire una storica separazione tra le
e lennon rendendo
difficili punti d'incontro
di unione e possibili alleanze
e da questa alleanza che chiedo oggi
vorrei che le istanze delle persone che
fanno sex worker venissero ascoltate
inclusa nei femminismi perché ne fanno
parte perché non c'è femminismo non c'è
più femminismo senza le sex worker
vorrei che ci fosse ascolto dialogo non
giudizio sorellanza
smettiamola di viverci uniamoci
alleiamoci creiamo assieme una società
diversa una società che non abbia paura
di parlare di sesso
una società che non abbia paura di
educare alla sessualità
in italia ancora oggi
non abbiamo un educazione sessuale
obbligatoria nelle scuole
è il 2021 e direi che piuttosto
vergognoso
un'educazione sessuale
che dovrebbe partire dall'anno zero che
dovrebbe essere sex positivi inclusiva
non giudicante che dovrebbe insegnarci
ad abbattere stupidi pregiudizi e
stereotipi
che dovrebbe insegnarci a rispettare
tutte le manifestazioni della sessualità
tutte le identità di genere gli
orientamenti sessuali
un'educazione sessuale che dovrebbe
insegnarci annuncio di cari corpi altrui
a non attribuire un valore ad una
persona sulla base dell'aspetto estetico
un'educazione sessuale che dovrebbe
aiutarci a riconoscere ad affrontare la
violenza di genere ea non esercitarla la
violenza di genere ad esempio facendo
cup calling pensando ma soltanto un
complimento no è una molestia
un'educazione sessuale che ci renda
consapevoli dei nostri privilegi
abbiamo bisogno di un'educazione
sessuale che ci insegna a non giudicare
le donne le persone per come quanto con
che perché fanno sesso
tutte e tutti sex worker e non abbiamo
bisogno chi si smetta di giudicarci per
quello che facciamo con il nostro corpo
vogliamo essere libere libere di
camminare a notte fonda libera di
indossare quello che ci pare libera di
accedere a tutti gli spazi alle
posizioni lavorative
vogliamo essere liberi di non essere
madri libere di abortire
vogliamo essere liberi di non aderire a
degli standard di bellezza normativi
libera di non depilarsi vogliamo essere
libera di fare sesso con chi ci pare di
farlo a pagamento di non farlo ha fatto
perché il corpo e la vita è la nostra
se la è colei che rompe le
regole
che osa che non si accontenta che occupa
lo spazio che alza la voce che è libera
di desiderare e dimostrarsi
fatemi un favore
la prossima volta che vi daranno della
voi fermatevi
alzate la testa e rispondete si
e fiera
[Applauso]